you were also listening to the comments
from the CEO of Lufthansa what was the
biggest stand out to you the biggest
supplies that you heard the biggest
surprise that this seems to be a
deliberate action it appears that the
plane was taken over manually without
any kind of autopilot being in control
and it looks like it's deliberate action
from everything they're saying and how
unusual is a part of that is that one of
the pilots of course left couldn't get
back into the cockpit the copilot
locking him out how unusual is it for
one pilot to leave the cockpit during a
flight well we're we're talking about
this is international here in the US
it's required that if a crew member
leaves the cockpit for example to use
the laboratory that another crew member
has to be in the cockpit such as a
flight attendant in the instance here
it's a foreign country they did not have
their requirements so there was in fact
one person in that cockpit by themselves
that wouldn't happen here in the US oh
well what part of that I don't want to
make you speculate here but what part of
that is not only European rules but
perhaps it was a budget airline so they
didn't necessarily have the crew members
for that no the it would it would be a
regulation that would be in place and
they would be forced to comply if that
was in fact the case but for more
reports and from what I'm hearing that
was not the case they are not required
to have another individual in the pilot
it wouldn't be a matter of the airline
you know a financial constraint there
are slated tenants on board an airplane
and if needed they would in fact be in
that in that cognitive if the
regulations were in place Kyle how do
you understand that the structure of the
door the lock ability I guess of the
door apparently there's a lever that the
person inside the cockpit can operate
which either opens the door or lock sit
and apparently there's also a keypad on
the outside so how could you lock
someone out or how could you get in if
you were outside basically there's a
position control between the pilot and
the copilot there's unlock there's
normal operation and there's unlock if
that's unlocked the door would be closed
and anybody would be free to enter from
the outside into the cockpit area if
that control was in the normal position
that keypad would be enabled so in other
words a flight attendant or the pocket
where the core the pilot could actually
dial in that cone and gain access to the
cockpit in this case it appears that was
on the locked position which would
disable that keypad so there would not
be any kind of entry allowed via that
remote keypad on the passenger side of
the cockpit door what kind of other
solutions might there be to sort of help
navigate this in the future to sort of
yes have the failsafe on the outside but
also have a fail-safe from the inside
you know I think the way the system is
here in the US it really works perfectly
and this is a you know that if this is a
criminal act and would be a bad apple in
the bunch I don't think any regulation
changes necessary here in the US but
what I think this is going to do for
foreign countries they're gonna
reevaluate reevaluate that I think it's
gonna wind up being like the policy here
in the US is where they it's required to
have two individuals in the cockpit at
all times I wonder how the investigation
will go from here I mean they're still
looking for as far as I understand it
the second voice recorder the second
contents of the black box which was
found empty and they have to what
evaluate whether or not the copilot was
actually conscious or he had to be
conscious because he was physically
locking the door yeah that is correct
and you know they're gonna they're going
to analyze that they're going to analyze
recordings are going to scrutinize this
co-pilots history his medical history
his financial condition is there any
reason for him to bring that airplane
down the look at his bank accounts as
his bank balances go talk to his family
to his friends to his co-workers to see
if there was any unusual activity in the
days prior to
to this incident I the Lufthansa CEO
said the copilot was deemed a hundred
percent fit to fly and that they did he
did undergo a thorough exam quote what
does that mean what kind of exams are we
looking at that would be basically two
in what's here in the US known as a
first-class medical exam it's done every
six months and it's basically a full
physical examination you know of the
individual everything from you know
checking your heart rate blood samples
drug tests that sort of thing just like
a normal person would go for you know a
routine physical but more in depth there
would obviously be an EKG involved to
make sure this person is in the correct
state but the one thing I want to say is
uh you know there's not any kind of
psychological testing in most medical
routine certifications so this might
have happened in the very beginning when
he was higher there might be a brief
psychological exam depending on the
under Airlines procedures but after that
it's typically you know a six-month
evaluation